you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network
this is American history podcast and
each week I Dave Anthony read Astoria
for Magnus in my body
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about why like that
why don't why don't you Gareth Reynolds
just that's how we do it and I don't
really understand what's happening right
now but I should certainly don't like it
we're talking to Gareth Reynolds from
the dollop about the inner workings of
the dollop what what is it you don't
like about being interviewed Gareth I
thought I was not prepared for that
right now
that's I do not like that you don't like
the fact that you're turning the intro
of the podcast then do an interview
thing which makes know some of it's an
entry thing as much it is it is an
interview I don't want to do this if you
have quite what did give me some
questions what are your questions what
was it like growing up and and when did
you become afraid of history alright
okay we're good we're good here feel
good I'm I'm talking to Gareth Reynolds
from the dollop about his podcast at
what point did you become David
Anthony's nemesis okay I'm not I'm not
gonna do this because we're not Nemus I
and you're Dave it's just stupid the
whole thing is incredibly stupid when
did you stop yes anding improvisation
when it I you know when it's based so
close
now hit him with the puppy you both
present sick arguments miss he died my
friend
Hey
hey buddy how are you good you back to
normal feel okay we're talking about
okay good
did you do that interview with the guy
sent over you can we have a lot of dates
coming up David well first I'll say this
I have an album called riddled with
disease you can buy at my website
Karen's calm also I will be in Australia
at the end of January into February
I'm added dates to Perth and Adelaide
celebrate Adelaide I'll be there
celebrate well the 24th and 25th of
January that I see June before him in
January and then the 23rd of January I
will be in Perth I'm at the Rhino room
in Adelaide and I met Rosie O'Grady's in
Perth and then we'll be on tour the
dollop is heading out on the road for a
lot of dates we're gonna be in San Jose
San Francisco Salt Lake City Denver
Vancouver at the Just for Laughs comedy
festival Cincinnati Pittsburgh Cleveland
two shows in Seattle both of which are
now on sale two shows in Portland both
of which are now on sale Houston Austin
Dallas Oklahoma City Nashville another
festival st. Louis Kansas City Des
Moines West Palm Beach tampa orlando
louisville indianapolis your errands say
go cards when you said st. Louis did you
say Vancouver you did I did say
Vancouver and and my response to that is
keep it down you know we're not here to
hear your baseball opinions yeah no this
is a faux interview show about the show
we're doing I don't know if you which
has a site of NamUs i chat we do we do
name aside chats yeah it's like a
fireside button em aside yeah I think a
lot of people listening to this podcast
are exploring the sort of complicated
and exciting world of being a nemesis
and what it means and and and you know
it's always been sort of a cartoony
thing but now people are really started
getting a taste of it it's nice to have
a grounded one the ins and out
yeah that's what it's like to actually
understand the Nemesis relationship sure
and I'm doing a podcast on using fewer
words you should listen to it you'd like
it and really help you go cards Aaron
tells me my favorite picture is now no
longer on the Giants but I stopped pay
attention to the Giants oh that's right
you like football I'm a huge football
team won today barely did you not barely
yeah barely
the last bit against New Orleans didn't
have to do it against your team your
team was over I would that game is over
in the first minute and a half to
nothing in under two minutes I believe
yeah your your your team fell down and
rolled the ball into the end zone or
something that's what we've got yeah it
was pretty uh it was silly yeah well I
mean again and my team is also won the
Super Bowl more recently than your team
and you know that's one of the best
quarterback are you going you can't
leave it's not how arguments work you
don't just get to actually it is how are
you miss work what are you looking for I
was looking for the the plug ease the
plug II oh oh just like the Packers
football so for those of you listening
right now who are like why is the show
coming to a dramatic halt Dave is Buster
Keaton around the room looking for an
outlet for his iPad any found one I'm
just gonna cut that out
turn the Benny Hill music off air and
it's over you're quite the butthole
you're trying to keep this profession
that's my new album title great the
bottle at the butthole
I like it
I was driving over here and I was
listening to God I'm so tired I'm
suggesting that's not the best
comedian white beard the fight what
white beard the whole gray beard gray
beard
it was like a classic old guy
Carlin
oh I mean I I know you're talking about
one of the greats with the idea that
even Carl because like yeah ok I said I
would never listen to it my legacy be
George you'll be known for your beard on
my phone and then I was listen tour on
iTunes music uh-huh they just stopped
halfway through well people say a lot of
people like the setup more than anything
they just like to hear like oh there's a
map I don't need to know if he got there
September 12th
1944 year of our Lord Jesus Christ
no we thank the Lord for the stuff we're
about to receive and go get him
really Leonard Peltier was born in Grand
Forks North Dakota okay what's his name
belt here Peltier held here his mother
was half Sioux and his father was three
quarters oh gee boy okay his father
served in Germany during World War two
where Leonard said he was quote machine
gunned in the legs Wow
but survived okay I don't know if his
legs were still there but probably not
super functional machine gun he was
machine gun and that's a lot of bullet
well those bullets come out fast yeah I
don't know I mean that's the thing that
a synonymous with machine guns yeah
Leonard's parents separated when he was
four Leonard and his younger sister then
moved in with their paternal
grandparents at a small ranch on the
Turtle Mountain Indian Reservation in
North Dakota ten miles south of
okay in 1950 they moved to Montana and
soon after they were living there three
white kids here we go
started throwing rocks at Leonard one
day while yelling quote hey you dirty
Indian go home I don't care if you're a
kid
is there a dumber thing to yell in
America is there a dumber sentence in
American history then hey Indian go home
is there a dumber one you can only equal
it I know I don't know I'm just leaving
the door open because I haven't heard it
yet but I would hate to say that that is
but me but it is I mean it's like yeah
it's not great no it should clearly be
Leonard throwing rocks being like go
home white people's right one rock hit
Leonard so he quote picked up a rock the
size of a marble and I hit him on the
temple I seen blood and with his
screaming I panicked and ran straight
home okay I mean by the way is that that
is what we like to call America's
foreign policy well he hit he hit I mean
you know he was right to throw a rock
back yes but then the second that you
get hit you're like yeah sure enough the
kid's mother came to his home yelling
that Leonard had tried to kill her son
clearly yep Yeah right
his grandmother did not speak English so
she was unable to answer cool this just
made the white woman more angry sure
yeah well I mean if you're here learn
our language oh wait yeah wait and she
called his grandmother a quote stupid
Indian where do you think the kid
got this from I don't this energy and
this yelling when they were thrown yeah
mix videogames she said she was gonna
have the entire family jailed the next
day the people yeah the next day the
Appel tears move back to North Dakota
why I don't know yeah weird a car yeah
it was the economy they can get a job
there late 1952 Leonard's grandfather
died of pneumonia the family struggled
and in 1953
Leonard was sentenced to a Wahpeton
Indian school we've never done an
episode in Indian schools but
essentially they put Native America you
have a long weird hair that's not yours
that's my to your chin that's mine not
yours okay
essentially it was to completely strip
them of their native Amer oh God
that should not be called Indian school
yeah the forced assimilation
indoctrination nation to white American
culture by forbidding any native of
American culture upon arriving well I
mean that is so that really is like I
mean it's pretty history it's slow a
slow erosion of this but it's so
you I mean were you around in England
when you were a kid when they would not
say the names of Irish things on the
television it would just be not long
enough to remember okay I'm sure I was
you know I think when they talked about
the IRA or or they certainly did not
allow the Irish to speak their their
native tongue right oh yeah so it would
it would just be a blank nothing
happening on the TV like it it's its
historical it's been going on forever
you don't let people speak things you
don't let them have their culture right
and you break them it's same thing they
did in Wales they know it's like you're
breaking the cycle yeah yeah except in
this way it's your personal history
which is cool
upon arriving quote our heads were cut
military-style next we were there was
cut hair was cut okay
heads well he said heads yeah but I just
want to clarify it because yeah that's
weird military-style head cut seen the
looks of those not the same it's not
great it's not a great look
next we were stripped and DDT was poured
oh Jesus Christ
and then we were march in a line to wait
for our turn to shower this is a school
yep if there was any dirt or dead skin
left when we were finished we were
turned around and given a few hard
whacks with a school rule ruler and told
to go rewatch so essentially prison yes
right right yeah it sounds like prison
yeah but again the family cannot feed
their kids and they feel the only thing
he can do to let them survive is the
sign up to these schools sure students
were beaten for climbing trees Jesus
we're making their beds too slowly and
for speaking their native language right
that's cool yeah cool that's cool
because they're kids yeah it's not scary
that's right right after four years at a
Wahpeton Leonard graduated in 1957 he
moved in with his mother and in Grand
Forks that winter they were low on fuel
and we're worried they would run out as
a storm was approaching okay so 13-year
old Leonard and a friend drove to an
Army Reserve depot to steal some fuel
they were caught siphoning fuel from
trucks and Leonard spent the next two
weeks in jail 13 yeah when he was like
this is better than school in mid 1958
his father took him back to the Turtle
Mountain Reservation and a tribal
meeting Leonard saw an old a jeep a jeep
waaah woman pleading for someone to help
because her children were at home and
they were slowly starving to death 1958
quote she asked if there were no more
warriors among her men
she said if there was why did they not
stand up and fight for the starving
children
that day Leonard vowed to help us people
for the rest of his life there we go by
1959 as part of the government's
termination policy Jesus Christ who
phase-out reservations turtle mountains
Bureau of Indian Affairs announced it
would stop supplying free food Wow so it
seems the opposite of termination policy
yeah
the jiwa took the Bureau of Indian
Affairs superintendent hostage in his
office and the bureau relented glad it
worked
yeah we'll take it but this is what he's
seeing right so he's a young he's a teen
and he's seeing the boot of the white
man on the throat of his culture and
then how you respond right right oh that
and then yeah that you can actually via
violence and threats get somewhere at 17
lesson yeah it is very good lesson at 17
Leonard moved to Seattle when he was
there he got in a fight and his jaw was
broken he was supposed to wear a brace
but he didn't
oh his jaw was broken okay okay and then
one night he was partying and he got
into another fight no and his jaw was
broken again it's fixed holy fixed
it quote but this time the muscle didn't
heal properly and my jaw came out kind
of stiff yeah the rest of his life is
jaws a little stiff yeah okay
let her joined the Marines to fight in
Vietnam okay but he was discharged to do
his jaw no I didn't actually dig into
that but I'm betting it was a financial
thing I just can't imagine I mean maybe
it wasn't oh the reason why I joined
yeah I just can't imagine him based on
who I know the person is right but you
know maybe I'm wrong okay he worked as a
welder and construction worker in
Seattle and buy new jobs get it close
that flame by 1965 a 20-year old a
Leonard Cohen a Seattle auto body shop
he turned the second floor into a
halfway house for Native American
who were struggling with alcohol and who
people had just gotten out of prison
mm-hmm because they were all struggling
to the reservation yeah so I'm gonna new
him at the time a letter said quote
Leonard always had girls and money in
his pocket because he's a real good
worker and people liked him he's always
been good hearted he just liked to laugh
and tease in 1968 President Johnson
ended a termination policy okay and
began the long process of restoring
sovereignty to over a hundred tribes
okay that's they're so little
they're still tribes struggling for
sovereignty particularly in California
Los Angeles also I don't believe our
tribe does not have sovereignty the
native tribe here that year the American
Indian Movement which I will now call a
I am was founded his leaders were Ojibwa
Dennis banks Oglala Lakota Russell Means
in 1970 Leonard took part in his first a
I am action a takeover of fort Lawton
outside Seattle Leonard and thirteen
others were beaten by police and
arrested and then beaten again in their
cells then it refused to leave the jail
until the others had all been released
Wow one later one later seventeen I
really the the depth of character to
head do that is crazy
yeah they're gonna be like you're free
to go is like I'm one later said he was
quote already a leader well we can't
have brown leaders in America Leonard
attended an AI am meeting in Minnesota
where Dennis banks said if the am wanted
to be taken seriously they had to cut
down on all the drinking drugs partying
groupies and the quote Saturday night
warriors okay I don't know what that is
I feel like that's like a party Chris
yeah party crew Mike Leonard Leonard
quit drinking on the spot Wow
in 1971 he returned to Turtle Mountain
but he was missing the activism
and he moved with banks to Los Angeles
but Leonard did not like LA quote it
seemed to me like kind of a jungle but
fair non create one he moved to
Milwaukee to help the Indian community
there with alcoholic issues okay
I'll be using Indian a lot because of
the words he used okay just yep
in October 1972 the am organized the
trail of broken treaties Wow which was a
car caravan from the west coast to
washington DC to gain attention for the
AI m and its plan for justice from the
american government okay
the Leonard was in charge of security in
DC and when they got there President
Nixon refused to meet with the leaders
so the am occupied the Bureau of Indian
Affairs headquarters for five days Wow
seventies were great they caused a
property damage and took documents they
said proved government discrimination
Wow five days I mean seriously like
today think of how long that would
actually last how long would that last
there were so many 30-minute covers back
then yeah no no they were and well I
mean just in general like yeah sit-ins
and where it was just like where
you just be like all right they are
expressing themselves and they would let
you do it
and now they would like have a battering
ram and like drag you out and and and
you know the left was more the left back
then there's not well there was a left
yeah well I mean I think that back then
you would consider a lot of Democrats
the left but ya know I don't think you
would so because they're the right yeah
so Leonard returned to Milwaukee and on
November 22nd 1972 I mean if I'm the
luckiest yeah but trust me in November
22nd 1972 he and a friend ran a
restaurant when two white men started
pointing and laughing at them I'm not
from there let it said quote what the
so funny great as you're supposed
to do when someone's pointing at you
laughing for sure you throw the pebble
yeah
the white men pulled out their guns well
that's when you're like boy guys
you know the other guy's not laughing
fine cuz you're laughing and pointing
the guys behind you were ignoring you're
laughing at not pointing which I take
issue with turns out these were playing
clothes cops but even then there's zero
justification for firing you still get
to tell cops you still got to say to a
cop you should be able to say to a cop
in America what the so funny but
it will in some instances get you killed
and a lot of instances get you arrested
but it wouldn't have a while ago like
you could mean things have changed right
and mile I mean if you're brown you're
always getting right and that is the
difference but if you're a white guy
back then you can probably you he's
like hey chill down I mean they were
busting a lot of heads you know we're
turning Vietnam yeah
so the Leonard was at handcuffed and put
into a paddy wagon one of the cops
started quote beating on me like a
stepchild
it's a telling it's a telling way of
putting it and in all these I would be
like if you went out with someone who is
pounding a lot of booze like you drink
like a father and in all these
skirmishing around my coke gets ripped
open and this old piece falls out hell
it was an old busted beretta couldn't
even fire I had just given a guy 20
bucks for it as a favor figuring I might
get it fixed sometime one of the cops
claimed the Leonard took it out and
pulled the trigger twice but it did not
fire yeah we go Leonard was charged with
attempted murder the cops girlfriend and
then the cops girlfriend later say that
he had previously waived a right before
this he had waved a photo of Leonard at
her while claiming he was going to quote
catch a big one for the FBI they can
catch a Native American but not a guy
eating people in his apartment by the
way Native American name of the town
every city there is Native American name
there like get him yeah
Leonard served five months and they
caught Dahmer by the way well some other
guys got eaten after that I mean he they
could they come look you come on
name one clue the the naked guy running
screaming please name one other clue
please help me not even a guy a young
team yes yeah yeah yes I believe he was
Laotian he was gonna say okay yes okay
something running in the street naked
yes say yes please God help me yes and
the cops laughed it off and let his
Dahmer came over and said this guy's on
some drugs he's been drinking come on
you don't have you net you let me tell
you okay you went to college you don't
never have a friend who ran down the
street naked screaming help me help me
help me because he was afraid of the man
who had a skull shrine in his apartment
get over yourself mister you can cast a
lot of dispersions if you like but let
me tell you something the police force
of Milwaukee was right on top of Dahmer
at the right time they caught him after
he ate only 13 get over it
Leonard sir regular chocolate factory
worker
Leonard sir five months before the am
was able to post his bail Wow during
that time the Pine Ridge tribal council
President Richard Wilson created the
guardians of the Iguala nation okay also
called goons okay a white security force
on so literally goons calling their
organization goons and created by a
Native American who's in charge well
well it's old school and we're seeing it
now old school versus young school we're
seeing a serious breakdown and but the
idea what is the the the Native American
who he want he wants to have a white
force its authoritarian as me
controlling the reservation okay it
seems yeah I didn't really look into him
because there was a lot going on there
Wilson was rabidly against the AI M okay
so the goon squad attack Native America
ponent opponents on the Pine Ridge
Reservation this led to fighting and an
armed takeover
Wounded Knee by M and Lakota men and the
year again
is this like 50 1970 72
oh right 72 yeah and what you just said
was that there was a white invasion of a
reservation an invasion he just hired a
bunch of well still like essentially I
mean the whites already control it they
just whites walking on a reservation
controlling yeah yeah it was a 71 day
standoff between
basically the am the Lakota the goons
the Tribal Council and and the FBI and
law enforcement on the other side right
when letter got out he headed straight
for Wounded Knee but it ended before he
arrived he did not think he was going to
get justice in court for the you know
fake one trying to shoot me charge so he
went to Seattle and missed his July
pre-trial hearing making him a fugitive
right on October 17th pedro Bissonnette
who was at the takeover of Wounded Knee
was killed by the Bureau of Indian
Affairs police who claimed he resisted
arrest
that old chestnut yeah the classic then
October 21st a car registered in a
Leonard's name took part in a shootout
with BIA police near bissonnette's
funeral okay the two officers received
minor injuries the car got away so they
couldn't say who was in it okay on
September 20th
Leonard was arrested near Seattle with
other a.m. members in charged with
possession of illegal weapons Leonard
gave a false names get bail and went
underground ice Academy you just give a
fake name Dave I remember so clearly
being able to get fake names in high
school it was all I would do it was the
best if you had no idea idea they'd be
like what's your day if you'd be like
John tinsel torch jimmy-jam Thompson
yeah and they'd be like all right date
of birth you're 48 yep
wait a minute this is not in March 1984
that'll be face facial recognition which
will be better in March 1980 and 1975
banks called the for quote warriors to
come to Pine Ridge and help out with the
goons lawyers he said the goons were
quote shooting into houses and throwing
bottles of cars and just running all
over the traditional people Jesus nearly
everyone on the reservation at this
point was armed few dared to walk
outside during march at least seven
people including two children were
killed on the Pine Ridge Reservation BIA
police showed a little interest in
getting involved yeah because they're
like hey look it's taken care of
yeah it's taken care of itself yeah when
when has that ever not gone away Jesus
they told a woman they told one woman
two of her relatives had died act
accidentally one had been hanged and the
other chopped to pieces with an axe an
accident
I did stumbled the lady she stumbled 34
times into an axe
we had a noose hung up for a pinata
thing we're doing later he jumps and run
in any trip that he fell up the stairs
up the stairs a nick first into the
noose we run up to help bottom drops out
that's a gun same time your boy Jimmy
he's he's he's accidentally getting her
it's thirty thirty five four times the
next that happens because you when you
put an active father swingy thing and
you're also probably saying why did you
not recognize this to be a person well
she was wearing a log cost thank you
thank you and this was one of those she
was resisting a log case is closed
yep we closed it we looked into all yep
so that's it we burned them another
episode of Bureau of Indian agency
police good guys on April 2nd the FBI
issued a a few
alert for Leonard saying he was armed
and dangerous
in May Leonard's great if they put that
out for the FBI at some point just be
fair we are armed and dangerous okay
inmate Leonard's group moved on to the
Iguala property of the jumping bull
family it became like a local tribal
community center they had free alcohol
counseling auto repair firewood and a
community garden just so you know
Native Americans still don't have enough
firewood right like today on
reservations they are freezing in their
homes because they don't have enough
fuel to burn the Iguala
community loved them and especially
Leonard who took over as leader when
banks left
Leonard also had a huge personality and
a global resident quote crazy guy but
fun good crazy not nuts really fun to be
around
easy you can't say crazy doing it but so
by this time Leonard had seven children
from two marriages and two adopted
children okay ladies he's big family
he's out there on June 23rd the Iguala
lakota jimmy eagle stole the cowboy
boots of a white man during a drunken
fight on the reservation okay my guess
is that this white gentleman lets
clarity sink in and calmly it has for
his boots back eagle
he said eagle had used the knife eagle
denied using a knife but he was carrying
it and he was charged with felony
robbery and assault with a deadly weapon
now this gave the FBI jurisdiction it's
a felony right a warrant was put out for
his arrest on a June 25th FBI agents
Ronald lambs and a jack Collier entered
the jumping bull property looking for
Eagle
they were told that he hadn't been seen
in a few days they were they were teeth
at more than one building they went into
a small building but
not going to the main compound building
okay the next morning a resident was
driving a half mile away when he saw a
hundred fifty law enforcement men
gathered before noon
agents hit picnic Williams in Collier
returned it is not known who shot first
oh boy but a gunfight started besides I
am members many non-member locals were
there including at least eight children
and three pregnant women most started
running away as the shooting went on
Leonard and a few others State William
and Collier were both shot non fatally
from a distance okay then one or more
people walked up to the two agents and
shot them three times each from close
range killing them no law enforcement
saw the shootings right they were
immediately surrounded by FBI BI police
local and state police the u.s. marshals
SWAT teams goons and other local white
agitators right I just
Leonard's crew believed quote we were in
all probability going to die before the
day was done they were not just gonna
arrest us they were gonna kill us
right yeah of course well I mean based
on the track record Fair instinct a
couple of things in this puzzle Native
Americans and FBI mm-hmm
so anyway I'm done with my arguments I
think it ended pizza so but then quote
an eagle came out and flew down and sat
in a tree above us and then flew away
and we knew that was the direction we
should go so they went in the direction
the Eagle went and they got away what do
you imagine if that goes south I know
like oh no they're in here too
we got him there you go we got it I wish
that my life was commanded more about
today hold McQuaid there's a puma I'm
actually following a snake trail
I believe there's water nearby wait what
trust me
and at 1:30 p.m. the law surrounded a
cabin on the compound and ordered
everyone to come out with their hands up
from inside two men fired a warning shot
then made a run for it okay the cops
blasted away shooting Joe kills right
through the head last night Ron it's not
a great name for the what would happen
yeah yeah it's a bad bad it's an omen
for yeah I'm gonna shoot out with a guy
named kills right you're like maybe we
should separate the other man his
brother-in-law escaped after a few hours
of walking Leonard's group was seen by
officers in the distance and they opened
fire but then the Eagle appeared again
not this eagle and again they followed
it to safety he's a fast eagle ever rady
GLE special FBI and SWAT units were now
flying in from all around the country
and a group of white ranchers called the
civil liberties organization who owned
some reservation land were given no aim
no a helicopter what a chemical warfare
team a team of snipers and for SWAT
teams what these are literally just
ranchers and they get all that
they get essentially and what are they
under military force yes and there which
by the way use the sound crazy to just
give to people but and they're just now
allowed to just if they're just gonna go
up part of the hunt Wow at 5:30 p.m. the
white cops and white ranchers raided the
main house on the compound so they're
involved in the raid Wow
it was an but the the main house is
empty except for joke it's like bring
your white to work day it's empty except
for joke kill writes body ok kills
writes Cecilia a jumping ball returned
later that evening and an officer told
her that two men had been killed on her
property okay Cecilia pointed at kills
Wright's body and asked if that was one
of them no that guy fell he no
nope yeah yeah yes yes
the officer said no quote that's just an
Indian Oh
so when he said been two men have been
killed he meant he the white guys were
killed then that is who that is and
that's a policy FBI right agent also the
family photos on the wall all the family
photos on the wall everybody's been shot
through their head in the family photo
oh Jesus Christ
but it's weird when you give a bunch of
Rancher vigilantes and watch and let the
SWAT team FBI and yeah everything under
darkness Leonard's group made it to a
remote cabin of Noah wounded the uncle
of an AI M member at for Ian's babies
always in there making pancakes
you guys were killing this you guys what
do you feel like swimming go tell us
follow me to a pond come on follow me
so at 4:00 a.m. the next morning a bomb
shattered the windows at Mount Rushmore
visitor center 80 miles away Wow
no one was injured but now also no one
claimed okay that day is the the South
Dakota Attorney General said it was time
to stop being quote soft on the Indians
just because they are a minority group
white people yeah white people it's just
it's relentless it's relentless
it's it's everywhere over the next days
a Leonard's group slept under trees
during the day and moved during the
night Leonard with Dino Butler and Bob a
rib ado became the leaders they spent
July in various safe houses around Pine
Ridge an AI m spokesman said the a.m.
would quote not apologize for the deaths
of the two FBI agents until the US
Justice Department apologized for the
deaths of all those Indian warriors
killed in the past three years what come
on command
oh right so basically at Pine Ridge you
know they just spent three years of
shootouts and just people
getting killed left and right and I mean
it ton again have been killed again it's
what happens when you're an occupying
force yeah yeah and now to to occupiers
get killed yeah it's I mean essentially
it is the policy of when you hold your
finger in front of someone's face and
you go don't touch me don't touch me
don't touch me don't touch me
yeah and he said the FBI would sorry
and he said the a.i.m would step up it's
C South Dakota last anti tourism
campaign next year now that is an
interesting nod so the next year is 4th
of July the Bicentennial so huge
celebration all of America and tourists
are expected to just pour into Mount
Rushmore for the celebrations and he's
saying that they're gonna start a
campaign saying you're not gonna want to
do that right very smart the state
attorney general said quote the only way
to deal with these am leaders is to put
a bullet in their heads
sounds like terrorism I mean that is
that is not that's just not on July 4th
an FBI helicopter let me go back to
England it's not great over there right
now well it's not now on July 4th an FBI
helicopter was shot down over Pine Ridge
with no casualties Wow
on July 8th Jimmy Eagle turned himself
in to police the FBI began an
investigation known as res MERS into the
agent Colliers and Williams murders Jo
kills Wright's death was never in vest
I mean I was just about to say it is
it's just nice a guy running yeah I got
running shot in the back most likely he
hit nothing than two agents who well you
just can do no wrong right even though
they're doing complete wrong most of the
time take care of your own read resumes
investigators were routinely Breaking
and Entering to get evidence and if
people will write to me and send in the
FBI good guys I can literally do a year
of podcasts about the FBI UK you could
do a dollop FBI right and have enough
content for a dead
right I mean the FBI is insane just look
at the terrorists they've arrested in
America it's all dudes they duped
who had no idea what was going on and
then like we the biggest terrorist
massive all time and it's guys like I
just want a sandwich like it's
crazy and some of the some of the things
that they have floated up the chain of
possibility are I mean Joel crazy no
nothing like a group that told MLK to
kill himself yeah and his family thinks
killed him
so Reznor's investigators were routinely
Breaking and Entering to get evidence
and illegally threatening and harassing
suspects and witnesses so they're just
yeah doing what they do doesn't matter
cuz it's a reservation and well yeah of
course and you are the law
raspberries led to four people being
charged for the murder of the agents Jim
Eagle Dino Butler Bob Reba do and
Leonard Peltier the u.s. Civil Rights
Commission called res MERS quote an
overreaction which which takes on
aspects of a vendetta weird
what and did they cite sources and that
little has been done to solve numerous
murders on the reservations but when two
white men are killed troops are brought
in from all over the country at a cost
of hundreds of millions of dollars silly
to which white people say exactly okay
so you get it so I don't know what the
problem is
in August Leonard's a group split up he
made his way to California and on
September 5th Dino Butler was arrested
on September 10th
Bob rib ado was arrested in Kansas he
had agent Colliers gun as well as an
ar-15 from the trunk of the agents car
okay
Leonard was now the only one still large
okay well November 14th
an Oregon State and what a scary feeling
yeah yeah November 14th an Oregon state
trooper misread FBI instructions to keep
him motor home under surveillance okay
he misread it and he thought he was
supposed to stop it okay wow that's
that's a great the first man out
was quote a large Mexican appearing
person he ordered him to lie down face
lie face down on the road this is one of
those times where like racism actually
sort of works to your because they think
you're Mexican yes they're just like so
inept at like being able to distinguish
our care to differentiate the Mexican
good work two women and a small child
also got out of the motor home then the
Mexican appearing man shot at the cop
and started running into the woods as
the cop returned fire as an Eagles like
this way that was of course Leonard he
was hit as he ran Jesus the driver of
the motorhome who also got away it was
Dennis banks the motorhome had been
given to banks along with $10,000 by
Marlon Brando well hello I mean honest
to god Marlon Marlon Brando yeah I mean
one of the good ones yeah I mean there's
some bad swell there's stuff crazy but I
mean as far as like his his attention to
Native American rights I'm talking
specifically was exactly that who was
like very much yeah yeah sure again this
was a different Hollywood now Hollywood
literally wouldn't give it I mean they
would just wouldn't care no you tweeted
about yeah sure link
Leonard was shot in the shoulder he
stole a pickup truck and went to
Portland where he stayed with a relative
for three days I am supporting doctor
treated his wounds okay
on November 18th he went to Canada where
he stayed in a cabin until mid-december
he was joined by a few a I am members
including his good friend Frank black
horse black horse would be after this he
would be the subject of persistent
rumors that he was really an Italian
American from Cleveland named a Francis
de Luca was a woman's name Rachel
Dolezal was it don't dull his clothes
also essentially he was Rachel Dolezal
and he was it was really yeah well
that's that's what theory yeah
and they're saying he joined the a.m
years earlier by right December 22nd
Leonard was put on the FBI's ten most
wanted list
that's just crazy again there's really
no he's really done no crime yeah I mean
there's a couple small things but he's a
voice they're saying he killed the man
and there's absolutely no right evidence
that he killed any one of the officers
and by the way on the same day when
other people were killed yeah yeah On
February 6 Canadian Mounties got a tip
and raided the remote camp of a crew
leader near Hinton Alberta they found
Leonard sitting next to a suitcase
containing four loaded guns the
arresting officer said Leonard shouted
quote I'm not gonna do anything you say
I have nothing to lose there was a
struggle and Leonard had to be pushed
hard against a wall Leonard was put into
a prison near Vancouver to wait
extradition Amnesty International called
Leonard's treatment in the prison
including isolation and body searches
quote unjustifiable his extradition
hearings began in May the ability for
our government and for us to so quickly
get rid of any dissenting voices because
the more that you peel that the more
that that becomes more and more
terrifying yeah I mean yeah the this the
simplicity with which they are able to
just completely for the most part not
only neutralize you legally but the way
that the public sentiment is able to be
poisoned so fast and you are so quickly
villain are vilified yeah I mean I'm
look I'm not a big conspiracy theory guy
but then when when people of color start
dying around an incident yeah one of
those being Ferguson yeah when all of
the leaders of Ferguson are dying being
killed or Eagle raids and Oh God
what's the guy who was selling loosies
in New York and
Garner oh yeah Conn his daughter dies
all the time yes 41 or something younger
she was like late 20s was she really
it's nuts when that starts
happening repeatedly that she's not the
only one yeah you know you're getting a
pattern and it's not something that is
it's not it's not hard
can we really in our in our world can we
imagine the crazy idea that someone
might have something that would cause a
heart attack and people I mean come on
no and the truth is to that it if you if
you believe that that's possible it's so
scary yeah and that's why people choose
not to yeah of course yeah of course
so his exit area its extradition hearing
start and one witness Myrtle Poor Bear
claimed to be his ex-girlfriend but
Leonard said they had never met she
submitted an affidavit claiming she'd
seen Leonard Bob Reba do Jamil and a
fourth person surround Coulier and
Williams and that Leonard fired the
shots that killed them so they have a
witness
eyewitness can I ask a question was she
and sag-aftra
Leonard's lawyers claimed he was a
political prisoner deserving asylum were
dashed they were like he yeah on June
18th while awaiting the judge's ruling a
fight broke out between Leonard
supporters and police the judge ruled
that sufficient grounds for extradition
had been presented and this was delayed
a bit when his lawyers appealed where
the extraditing to us oh oh right okay
so he's in Canada okay rib ado and
Butler's trial began in Cedar Rapids
Iowa they both admitted they'd exchanged
fire from a distance with Collier and
Williams but they denied being present
for the fatal close-range shots this
time prosecution didn't use Myrtle Poor
Bear because found an affidavit in which
poor bear had stated she left Oh golly
the day before the shootings
and that undercuts what she saw
yeah if she's not there it's hard to
witness that's right
interesting that's almost like there's
no witnesses to the shooting yeah right
but let him have another casting call I
think they'll find some great people
now there's only one supposes witness a
19 year old wish Draper and he testified
directly linking Riveter and Butler to
the murder
the defense convincingly argued his
statements were coached and even
fabricated okay he was an actor he was
legitimately an actor yeah stories of
horrible mistreatment on Pine Ridge
swayed public opinion and as the jury
deliberated 90% of the white town of
Cedar Rapids held a spontaneous March
supporting the defendant I mean can we
frame this moment and put it on the wall
of white for a second Wow that's that
really is a testament to I mean they
write they know them and they you know
yeah again the the people aren't the FBI
and right yeah right there people on
July 16th after five days of
deliberation the jury found
rubba do and Butler not guilty saying
they hadn't executed the cops and any
shooting they did was in self-defense on
December 16th Leonard was extradited to
Fargo North Korea even though in the
states because the judge had already
ruled that poor bears testimony was just
was justified the extradition right so
they could still do it based on that
yeah even though we now know she was
lying right pretty cool
Leonard was insane Leonard was in very
good spirits one of his lawyers said
quote here was Leonard on trial for
murder and he was trying to cheer us up
during the trial the judge routinely
interjected the to help prosecution
witnesses okay so we have a let me guess
the race of the judge Wyatt I mean are
there any other kind of judges of why he
repeatedly barred the jury from seeing
evidence
and like a judge is supposed to and from
hearing witnesses who would almost
definitely prove Leonard was innocent
right
so anybody who said he didn't do it it
wasn't there well I witnesses there he's
just like no Mandy that I
this included Myrtle Poor Bear who would
have testified that she had left that
the FBI coerced her oh my god into
signing the false affidavit for
Leonard's extradition so now you have a
witness arguably the biggest witness who
said he murdered someone she saw it and
now she's saying the FBI made her say
that and do that is is that damning the
judge said she was too unstable to
testify right right he barred Jimmy
eagle from testifying because his claims
of FBI misconduct would quote confuse
the jury yes and again that is not the
point of this the last thing you're
supposed to do is water down any of
their justice I mean come on you confuse
a jury you know what happens
that's a hung jury I mean that's a
problem I mean the whole idea of defense
is to confuse the jury Yeah right I mean
essentially to be like oh yeah that's
murky now that doesn't seem it's not a
hundred percent right right the
prosecution argued the most important
piece of evidence was a shell casing
from The Killers rifle that was found in
the trunk of the agents car four days
after the shooting after being missed by
initial investigators okay so they're
following the making a murderer theme
the the defense led by Elliot taketh I
don't know this is but apparently it was
a known New York attorney okay
it explicably failed to pounce on
conflicting and very suspicious
testimony from an investigating officers
about the chain of custody of the shell
casing nice including flimsy excuses for
why it wasn't tested until six months
after its discovery this is like this is
well this right here this thing about
the shell casing and being found four
days later and the big test is so common
that now it's a hockey theme right in
movies in which they're trying to frame
someone right
right this is before that trope yeah
when ballistic experts for the defense
prove the shell casing had not been
fired by any gun associated with the
killings prosecutors decided the ar-15
found during Roberto's arrest was the
murder weapon
what so I mean even their mercury
argument how do you so they prove that
the shell casing is right and
then they're like and it was this gun
yeah and then like yeah
Christ and it was too damaged for
experts that so the air 15 is too
damaged for experts to test if the shell
casing came from it so it's involvement
cannot be disproven right in the way
that I could say to you but you have to
prove beyond an innocent doubt so they
have to prove that that gun if they want
to say it did the truth that it did
yes that's what yes so you don't kill
that you don't sit down and go all right
defense poked some holes in the argument
that's full of holes
it's like know that you're any
reasonable doubt I mean this should be
filed under ridiculous doubt it's only
doubt on April 18th 1977 after six hours
of deliberation an all-white jury found
Larry go Peltier guilty on two counts of
first degree murder he was given two
consecutive life sentences the good guys
won
Jimmy Eagle would never be charged with
any crimes relating to the aging Coulier
in williams killings because they knew
they didn't want to do that again right
April 1979 and Leonard was transferred
to Lompoc prison in California where he
became a friend with a Mexican American
man named Bobby Garcia Bobby had escaped
prison twice in May a new inmate calling
himself
Richardson arrived at Lompoc and then
Leonard was told by someone outside the
prison here we go when it was contact no
way that Richardson was a fake name yeah
out of here he was actually Dick
Williams son-in-law the guys set up the
guns
and Richardson had been sent to kill
Leonard yeah holy
so Garcia arranged for Leonard to have
two inmate bodyguards with him at all
times
Wow still Leonard felt like his life was
in danger yeah because his life was in
danger oddly and your and your again
it's not like your it's not like you're
free like if you're getting into prison
under a fake name
that means the prison system completely
is behind it yes you can't just get into
prison using a fake ID no yeah no it's
not it's not a shitty bar at 8:30 p.m.
on July 20th 1979 Leonard Garcia a 19
year old Lakota Dallas Thunder shield
set fire right now
it's a amazing name Thunder
Shield yeah set fires in their cells
then used keys made by Garcia to reach
the prison fence Wow at this point
supporters outside the prison were set
up and they started shooting at guards
as the three climbed over the fence love
it but prison officials have been tipped
off there was a guard standing outside
near the exact place where they exited
he told the three men to freeze and they
did and then the guard shot thunder
shield in the back Jesus Christ
Leonard and Garcia then ran off into the
brush while the guard handcuffed a
thunder shield
as he was dying he the I mean the
American meet the shoot and cuff thing
is one of the heart and because now we
have access to seeing that huh to
desensitize us to make it normalized and
v Ryan eventually that's right it that
is truly one of like the most disgusting
and in a would see of disgusting
displays you have to put yourself into
the position of a person doing that and
if you and if you can shoot a man and
let's say they're not armed and let's
say they're not pointing a gun at you if
you can and that happens all the time
yeah if you can shoot and like in this
isn't a man in the back and then and
then hog-tie him yeah as he's dying
you're a psycho yes yes you did
you often you're a white supremacist yes
and you're doing what you want to do
dude
yes and the whatever yeah whatever
so thunder shield died one of Lehner's
supporters quote the guard was there and
he was ready he didn't know about
thunder shield who decided to join them
at the last minute and it looks like the
wrong lawn hair long-haired and Ian got
shot so Hugh meant he killed again it's
when racism somehow plays into the like
yeah a broken clock is Right twice it
like yeah he was an executioner yes and
he because of his inability to
differentiate shot the wrong person
that's right
Garcia was captured 90 minutes later
Leonard who was now armed with a rifle
given to him by supporter disappeared
into the hills the a.i.m called for
members to flood the area to confuse the
search right after five days of
wandering in the heat Leonard approached
a rural farmer at gunpoint the farmer
said quote I suppose you're gonna kill
me now
and letter replied no I'm not a killer
I'm a plea I'm a political prisoner I
don't go around killing people for no
reason at all in fact I haven't killed
anybody
let her take the farmers truck but let
him go even though killing the farmer
would have stopped him from calling
police
yeah and the farmer immediately called
police the Chuck brought down after two
miles and then the FBI and local police
tracked Leonard one of the detectives
said quote the information and that we
had on him was that he had a very
explosive character and that he would
not be taken alive that I mean even
though he's already been taken alive and
yes an explosive character where do you
think that comes from yeah I mean that
is the oldest stereotype of all time
when they caught up to Leonard he didn't
shoot at them after being handcuffed
Leonard said quote maybe I could have
gotten one or two of you but I'm not a
killer
talk about explosive character the
escaped added seven years to his
sentence which were two consecutive life
says yeah in 1983 Bobby Garcia was found
dead in
prison authorities said he hanged
himself but many believe he was murdered
United 84 we know as Epstein II yes in
1984 so now we were years I just gone by
in 1984 Leonard's original prosecutor
admitted the government still did not
know who killed Collier in Williams the
prosecutor who convicted him said in
1984 he and they did not know who killed
the FBI agents it's good detective work
in 1986 an appeals court acknowledged
FBI misconduct okay but still affirmed
Leonard's conviction sure that's how it
works in 1991 a trial ain't now retired
judge from that appeals court so the
appeals court that said the FBI had done
his conduct right but right he retired
and felt so shitty because he
knew Peltier had committed no crime that
he wrote to President Bush saying that
Leonard deserved to be set free due to
misconduct by the FBI and other
government agencies and they that did
that he did not pardon him or let him
out again
Leonard based on this requested a new
trial yes the Fargo judge again denied
the request in 1992 aim co-founder
Russell Means had a lead role in last of
the mohicans Dennis banks had a
supporting role means later voiced Pokot
is's father in Pocahontas meanwhile in
1993 a Leonard came up for parole and
was denied a former US Attorney General
petitioned President Clinton to pardon
Leonard
the nice the sweet democratic man the
president the Democratic president
President Clinton refused in 2004
Leonard ran for president as the Peace
and Freedom Party candidate in
California I vote for did you yeah he
got over 20,000 votes in 2009 he was
parole in 2012 a federal judge refused a
request by Leonard's attorneys to review
900 pages of FBI documents related to
Frank black horse / Francis de Luca who
had never been extradited from Canada
and remained there apparently free that
year curious Jackson Browne Pete singer
and a must deaf performed at a bring
Leonard Peltier healthier home concert
Wow at this point Nelson Mandela mother
Teresa the Dali Lama Ringo Starr had all
called for Leonard to be released a huge
campaign aimed at getting President
Obama to commute Leonard sentence
reached its peak on January 17th 2017
three days before Obama left office
Pope Francis personally reached out to
President Obama an appeal for Leonard
Peltier released President Obama refused
Leonard Peltier is currently held in a
prison in Florida he has diabetes high
blood pressure and a heart condition he
also has children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren he says he does not
know who killed FBI agents Koehler and
Williams he is next eligible for parole
in 2024 when he will be sent at 79 years
old how the does he not get a
retrial or a new trial judges say no but
that is so I mean the system has to say
the system is long it's the dumbest but
in fact there's not an outside body and
that is overseeing all of our court
systems and saying well no that's
actually that's actually ethical
prisoner you know there's a guy in
Philadelphia in the prisons for
the same reason there's guys all over
our country that are political prisoners
sitting in prisons because they were
good leaders and and in this case you
have a reservation that is being
annihilated by law enforcement people
being killed ax murders and the FBI is
not doing anything so when two FBI
agents are coming to your house they're
coming to kill you yeah
like that's the reality yes situation of
course yeah and then we know that the
FBI fabricated evidence had false
witnesses it's it's a slam-dunk
yeah that's why I think there's only one
President presidential candidate who
will for him myself I don't think there
are any except for Bernie Sanders who
will free Leonard Peltier not one not
one of those people will do it
and and this is this was like it's
pretty well known I don't I don't think
Obama was a good president and in some
ways I think I think my personal opinion
is Obama was the most cynical president
in my lifetime because more than anyone
else he got the youth of America to get
very excited about his election and then
he told them to off yeah and that
that was devastating and that led to I
don't know a lot of those people not
partaking in the next election weird
yeah that that would happen I want to
but guess who got elected but
this this to me when he did this yeah
don't think about how he didn't he
didn't prosecute Wells Fargo when they
were clearly clearly committing racial
crimes take us from five lawyers to
seven this to me is the most disgusting
thing he has ever done from an
empathetic human being
stand problem because the pardoning
process when you're leaving office is so
absurd
there is no repercussions well there's
the guy I can't remember things from
Kentucky whatever he just he's pardoned
like murderers pardoned a
pedophile yeah he's pardoned like and
and there is a little bit of a rubber
group but as of now you if you're the
president you can just commute or get
rid of sentences people the people are
excited for chunk to be out of office
but when that guy starts
pardoning oh you're gonna wish you were
never in this country he's gonna it's
gonna be like the TV show Gotham or you
although knees loose and that is best
case scenario that is best case scenario
I mean yeah yeah but yet to me that was
Obama's biggest crime that guy has no no
reason to be in prison yeah he is a
political prisoner in America because he
is a Native American and fought for his
people
and there's nothing else there literally
nothing else they're good times yeah is
this gonna be our Christmas weekend Epis
[Laughter]
I think so I think it's the Christmas
one
enjoy your full stockings you can have
it you can show this to your families
Wow okay yep maybe send Leonard a gift
in prison yeah well let's get the
address that's what we did with them
yeah we can send rocky Anderson all
right we'll put that up all right well
we sign enjoy your white Christmas yeah
just like the ones this country's always
know